Mula sa mga teleskopyo hanggang sa Large Hadron Collider
bawat bagong siyentipikong kasangkapan ay nag-imbento at nagbago ng mga tanong
na kami bilang mga siyentipiko
at mga mapagusisang isipan ay makatwirang maitanong
ang high performance computing o HPC
ay sumali sa natatanging listahang iyon noong dekada sitenta ngayon
ang mga quantum computer ay kumakatok na sa parehong pintuan.
Maligayang pagdating ang aking pangalan ay conducive to coffee
at isa akong software engineer dito sa IBM Quantum
sa kursong ito layunin naming turuan ang mga estudyante
at mga propesyonal kung paano ang quantum computing ay malapit nang
makipagtulungan sa mga imprastraktura ng HPC
upang makapaghatid ng computational
matututunan mo kung paano ang quantum
at mga klasikal na computer ay nakikipag-ugnayan at nagpapalitan ng data
kung paano magsulat ng mga programa na ginagamit ang parehong uri ng hardware
at kung paano binubuksan ng integrasyon na ito ang mga aplikasyon na malulutas natin ngayon
magtatayo ka ng praktikal na karanasan sa tunay na quantum hardware
at mga klasikal na high performance computing cluster
na nagpapatakbo ng mga quantum job kasabay ng mga tradisyonal na HPC workload
at matututo kang mag-interpret ng mga resulta nang may kumpiyansa
at matutukoy ang mga lugar kung saan ang quantum acceleration
ay tunay na makakatulong sa mga kalkulasyon
at kung saan hindi higit sa lahat mauunawaan mo
kung saan patungo ang kinabukasan ng mga computer
at ang mapa na magdadala sa atin doon sa tingin namin
ang kursong ito ay mahalaga
at napapanahon at naniniwala kami
na ang pagsasama ng mga teknolohiyang ito ay magiging mahalaga
sa pagkamit ng computational advantage
maaari itong magkaroon ng malawak na epekto sa iba't ibang industriya
tulad ng chemistry na posibleng magbigay-daan
sa mas mabilis na pagdisenyo ng gamot at pananaliksik sa mga materyales
sa finance
para sa mas matalinong mga modelo ng panganib
at fraud detection sa artificial intelligence at machine learning
para sa pag-optimize ng modelo sa kursong ito
malalim tayong sisid sa mga mapagkukunan ng computer
mga modelo ng programming at quantum algorithm
kaya maligayang pagdating at maging handa
marami tayong tatalakayin